jennifer lopez and ben affleck pack on
the pda in the city of love and there
amore is in the air
and when in paris do as the parisians do
here's bennifer kissing on a bench after
officially becoming mr and mrs affleck
last week the same day the couple was
spotted strolling the streets in france
looking oh so chic j-lo in a white
floral dress perfect for summer next to
ben in a blue button-up
and while they're all loved up e.t has
learned this actually wasn't their
honeymoon as jen's 14 year old emmy
tagged along the trip but it's
definitely a nice getaway after tying
the knot i've heard you say so many
times that you are a hopeless romantic
and you still believe in love you
believe in marriage you still believe in
all of those absolutely why wouldn't i
yeah just a few months after jyn told et
she was open to getting hitched again
the couple did the darn thing secretly
saying i do in an intimate vegas
ceremony
you look gorgeous
[Music]
somebody's getting married
jen and ben exchanged vows at sin city's
little white wedding chapel surrounded
by just a few of their nearest and
dearest
an eyewitness who saw the nuptials said
it was a tearful moment for both stars
as they were reading each other vows
they were very sweet they both were
emotional they cried to each other the
kids were right there behind them
as for how bennifer celebrated becoming
one well a source told e.t
pizza
yep they chowed down on pizza after the
ceremony before heading back to l.a
nothing crazy but you know just
definitely celebrate
but the wedding festivities are just
getting started
[Music]
a source tells e.t the couple's planning
a larger celebration in the future
reportedly at bin's property in georgia
quote they will absolutely be having a
bigger wedding ceremony and celebration
that includes close relatives friends
and loved ones just want to have a good
time for now have fun in the city of
love you married lovebirds
[Music]